lee
[Musique]
alors qui est cette personne et vous
avez une minute trente
vous posez des questions et ne peut
répondre que par oui ou par non pas
bernard montiel vous m'emmerdez chili
est ce que vous êtes fait vacciner par
olivier ferrand
non je me revois pourquoi il est là
est-ce que je vous dise à cause de sa
coiffure le coiffeur dit guillaume
genton non ça devient de très belles oui
je vais voir un don particulier non est
ce que vous êtes étudiant vous attendez
attendez chacun votre tour oui pardon
est ce que vous êtes étudiant non est ce
que vous avez fait l'actualité ces
derniers jours oui ah ah ah ah oui
nicolas pernikoff est ce que vous êtes
artiste non en juin plombé son angoisse
pour moi tana vous côtoyez où vous avez
côtoyé des gens célèbres oui ouest effet
une actualité drôle non politique
un peu un peu moins un peu c'est en
rapport avec les vaccins
est ce que vous avez réalisé un exploit
ou sauver quelqu'un non non non pas
vraiment car non est ce qu on a vu votre
visage partout oui oui oui puisque il
voit jamais rien non oui est-ce que vous
travaillez dans un bar dans un
restaurant
on se calme
maniche taureau s'il vous plaît je
venais la personne la parole à une
personne à merci cette personne pourra
poser une question si cette question et
la botte c'est terminé
[Applaudissements]
m
faux lui c'est terminé allez-vous moser
s'est terminée ce terminus terminus tout
le monde descend terminus après je vous
le dis il s'agit de damien est ce que
vous voulez qu'on repart pour 10
secondes oui oui
beinheim damian ce que vous avez servi
le président de la république se bat là
c'est exact
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon les mecs savent à peine le bon mot
ça va à nouveau oui mais est-ce que je
vais fermer votre gueule nouveaux axes
mbuyu et des bobos oui mais toi tu
allais voir la belle vache doit alors
oui merci
excusez moi mais sans déconner mais vous
êtes devenu sur les velléités
l'anarchique vous croyez où vous vous
croyez les terrasses sont ouvertes
[Rires]
c'est l'anarchie
ne faites rien n'y fait rien on va faire
connaissance avec damien d'amiante est
la star du jour a bien sûr vie emmanuel
mâcon et jean castex en terrasse
vous allez nous dire ce qui vous ont dit
ce qu'ils vous ont pas dit et s'ils ont
été faire un petit beat derrière vous
connaissez certainement damien puisque
damien c'est le serveur qui s'est occupé
ce matin de jean castex et emmanuel
macron alors et vous ça y est vous voyez
tout couvert de monde c'est incroyable
vous vivez je voulais un truc de fou
vous le savez ce matin qu'ils allaient
venir
en fait on a été vraiment prévenu 20
minutes avant leur arrivée
comment ça se passe et le patron et vous
dis attention ni à jean castex emmanuel
macron qui vont bien les agents de
sécurité de la gare de de monsieur mâcon
qui est venu nous annoncer que il allait
passer mais c'est beau et c'est qu'il a
choisi que savez-vous quelle et les
servir ça j'en sais rien du tout en tout
cas nous on fait qu'on est vraiment très
content et on aurait quand même d'avoir
pu servir et avoir accueilli monsieur
macro et monsieur castex le au premier
jour d'ouverture de réouverture des
terrasses vous aviez la pression pas
complètement grosse grosse angoisse quoi
il faut pas que je passe à côté quoi
cela ils ont pris quoi d un café à fait
vers nos caves et bien nous a même pas
une petite cartouche quoi rien ou tafer
maire de prison payer ou pas et il mine
pour bien viser qui sema qualité n'ont
même pas non à wade
c'était une belle image franchement on
va la voir cette image si on l'a bien
entendu je ne sais pas si loin prévu
savez quand je suis ici c'est moi et ma
chance au mieux aussi je suis comme toi
tu sais mais j'ai peur tous les soirs
[Musique]
et quand ils manuel macron ap jean
castex pour ne pas qu'on apprenait que
le mec est bien c'est bizarre il veut
dire mais je me reconnais moi
cette semaine il ya maxime saada le
président du directoire de canal+
j'ai envoyé un message evans est ce que
tu peux aller prendre un café ou là j'ai
tu m'as pris pour jacques beauvois est
généralement quand votre patron vous dis
on va prendre un café
c'est pas fou alors qu'est-ce qui vous
ont dit qu'ils vous disent pas à pas
grand chose ils nous demandent de rennes
failli me demande réellement si ça fait
du bien de revenir travailler
ouais bon s'arrêter de physique de berne
en clair on a été énorme avec le
président non franchement dans ce schéma
chez moi jouer à la play c'est vrai
surfant like to play est vrai que vous
avez entendu bien évidemment oui et je
vais même dit que vraiment on se rend
compte que la chanson qui dit le travail
c'est la santé c'est vraiment ça que
vraiment ça fait du bien d'aller
travailler à parisot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non non un peu c'est pas mal le
président le premier ministre et vous
avez votre patron est hélas oui
à bas la somme et même si je vais pas
venir ce matin oui il ya du déchet le
jour où il faut qu on a vu le coup de
stress d'un coup ah ouais on a su pour
de café vous êtes heureux très heureux
c'est vrai c'est un truc de fou
rendez compte on est on est heureux
d'aller c'est gabriel franchement damien
je le trouve moi son sourire ça me fait
plaisir bien sûr ça fait plaisir à voir
c'est tous ces patrons de bars de
restaurants qui n'ont pas pu travailler
tout laissait tous leurs salariés qui
ont pas pu travailler pendant des mois
on a juste envie de leur dire merci
parce qu'ils ont tenue et oui il
faudrait c'est la santé où il ne fait
pas travailler c'est aussi le fait de
voir beaucoup moins de monde c'est le
fait de se sentir pas forcément très
bien et donc merci d'avoir tenu et pour
nous permettre à tous de tenir et
permettra à l'épidémie de d'être contenu
et on est vraiment ravis que vous
puissiez recommencer à travailler on
espère que ça ira maintenant le plus
vite possible pour ceux qui ne peuvent
toujours pas travailler c'est-à-dire les
patrons de discothèques part ça devrait
arriver à l'arrière je crois que c'est
quoi 1er juillet les discothèques ce
qu'on a dit c'est qu'avant la fin juin
donne règne date d'accord et donc ils
seront fixés à ce moment là dès qu'on
considérera qu'on peut le faire que
c'est sécurisé de le faire on le fera
peut-être en utilisant le pass sanitaire
mais en tout cas dès qu'on pourra le
faire que ce sera sérieux de le faire on
sera